[Music]
you
why are gas stations always built right
next to other gas stations why is it
that I can drive for a mile without
finding a coffee shop and then stumble
across three on the same corner why do
grocery stores auto repair shops and
restaurants always seem to exist in
groups instead of being spread evenly
throughout a community while there are
several factors that might go into
deciding where to place your business
clusters of similar companies can be
explained by a very simple story called
hotelling's model of spatial competition
imagine that you sell ice cream at the
beach your beach is one mile long and
you have no competition where would you
place your cart in order to sell the
most product in the middle the one half
mile walk maybe too far for some people
at each end of the beach but your cart
serves as many people as possible one
day you show up at work just as your
cousin Teddy is arriving at the beach
with his own ice cream cart in fact he's
selling exactly the same type of ice
cream as you are you agree that you will
split the beach in half in order to
ensure that customers don't have to walk
too far you set up your cart a quarter
mile south of the beach center right in
the middle of your territory
Teddy sets up a quarter mile north of
the center in the middle of Teddy
territory with this agreement everyone's
south of you buys ice cream from you
everyone north of Teddy buys from him
and the 50% of beachgoers in between
walk to the closest cart no one walks
more than a quarter of a mile and both
vendors sell to half of the beachgoers
game theorists consider this a socially
optimal solution it minimizes the
maximum number of steps any visitor must
take in order to reach an ice-cream cart
the next day when you arrive at work
teddy has set up his cart in the middle
of the beach you return to your location
a quarter mile south of Center and get
the 25 percent of customers to the south
of you Teddy still gets all of the
customers north in Teddy territory but
now you split the 25 percent of people
in between the two carbs day three of
the ice cream wars you get to the beach
early and set up right in the center of
Teddy territory assuming you'll serve
the 75% of beachgoers to your south
leaving your cousin to sell to the 25%
of customers to the north when Teddy
arrives he sets up just south of you
stealing all of the southerly cost
and leaving you with a small group of
people to the north not to be outdone
you move 10 paces south of Teddy to
regain your customers when you take a
midday break
Teddy shuffles 10 paces south of you and
again steals back all the customers to
the far end of the beach throughout the
course of the day both of you continue
to periodically move south towards the
bulk of the ice cream buyers until both
of you eventually end up at the center
of the beach back to back each serving
50% of the ice cream hungry beachgoers
at this point you and your competitive
cousin have reached what game theorists
call a Nash equilibrium the point where
neither of you can improve your position
by deviating from your current strategy
your original strategy where you were
each a quarter mile from the middle of
the beach didn't last because it wasn't
a Nash equilibrium either if you could
move your cart towards the other to sell
more ice cream with both of you now in
the center of the beach you can't
reposition your cart closer to your
furthest customers without making your
current customers worse off however you
no longer have a socially optimal
solution since customers at either end
of the beach have to walk further than
necessary to get a sweet treat think
about all the fast food chains clothing
boutiques or mobile phone kiosks at the
mall customers may be better served by
distributing services throughout a
community but this leaves businesses
vulnerable to aggressive competition in
the real world customers come from more
than one direction and businesses are
free to compete with marketing
strategies by differentiating their
product line and with price cuts but at
the heart of their strategy companies
like to keep their competition as close
as possible
you